bonjour je m'appelle élevé l'année que
jolie 57% selon radio-canada cet autre
participation des jeunes entre 18 et 24
ans lors des élections fédérales de 2015
ainsi 43% des jeunes ne sont pas y voter
lors de cette élection
mais cet autre participation des jeunes
lors des élections ne date pas d'hier
en effet le plus faible taux de
participation depuis 1919 était observée
lors des élections provinciales de 2008
suite à ce résultat catastrophique le
directeur général des élections du
québec a commandé une étude à
l'université laval afin de comprendre
les raisons de l'abstention des citoyens
pourtant gib à aller voter
une des premières raisons énoncées par
cette étude fut l'histoire n'avait pas
la sensation que leurs votes importants
alors comment pourrions-nous modifier
notre système électoral pour remonter la
participation des jeunes lors des
élections puis je me suis rappelé qu'une
réforme du mode de scrutin avait déjà
été à bordeaux fédéral par match en
notre ministre du canada justin trudeau
lors de sa campagne électorale de 2000
km maman nettoyage en face à s'être main
problématique des queues de mon intérêt
face à la politique que j'ai développé
cet ami cours sur l'histoire du québec
et mon expérience au parlement des
jeunes qui est une simulation de
l'assemblée nationale
retourne à ma problématique il faut
d'abord saisir le fonctionnement d'un
mode de scrutin qui est le même poteau
fédéral qu'au provincial depuis la
création du canada nous utilisons le
même système
en effet depuis 1867 nous utilisons un
mode de scrutin uninominal à un tour
il faut d'abord saisir comment ça
fonctionne donc nous avons divisé en 5
ans qui sont le terreau tort selon le
mouvement population lors d'une élection
chaque partie peut présenter un self
candidats par circonscription
le candidat obtenant plus de vote
devient d'éviter cette circonscription
et le parti obtenant plus de sièges au
parlement
motivé le poste du gouvernement mais
c'est que les désavantages de notre de
sécurité dont examinons les résultats
des élections provinciales de 2014 le
parti libéral du québec
obtenir 56 % des sièges alors qu'il n'a
obtenu que 42% des votes les voitures
parlons ici du vote populaire mais non
fédérale lors des élections de 2015
le parti libéral du canada a obtenu 54 %
des sièges alors qu'ils ne tenu que 40 %
des votes
on observe un écart majeur entre le nom
de sièges le nombre de votes obtenus cet
accord peut faire la différence entre
gouvernements majoritaires ou
minoritaires
ici notre mode de scrutin actuel amène
une sur représentation du parti
vainqueur une sous représentation des
partis de l'opposition
mais plus particulièrement comment dans
le mode de scrutin actuel affecté notre
génération la génération z
examinons les propos du vice-président
du parti vert daniel green l'ordre
concernant les élections fédérales de
2015 on ne perçoit que 58 % des votes
exprimés en octobre 2015 au québec n'ont
pas côté saut j'appelle ça des bottes
poubelle c'est des votes qui n'ont pas
compté c'est des gens qui auraient pu
rester à la maison
m'imposer participer alors quand on
pense que 58 pour cent du vote populaire
ne pas été comptés au québec alors rien
un problème encore plus si difficile de
motiver nous les jeunes
la future génération z aller voter si on
sait que notre vote ne pas de valeur
aujourd'hui pour vous j'ai une solution
un mode de scrutin proportionnel mixte
compensatoire régionales qui pourraient
remédier à tous les problèmes des usines
aussi précédemment
donc faut comprendre que dans un mode de
scrutin mixte on divise notre processus
électoral en deux parties 50 % des 10
pts et serait élu la même façon qu
actuellement donc selon me de scrutin
uninominal à un tour
donc le candidat obtenant le plus de
votes dans sa circonscription de devenir
député de celle ci la grande nouveauté
de la solution vient avec l'utilisation
d'un mode de scrutin proportionnel
en effet l'autre 50% des députés
parlement serait élu
ce long processus proportionnelle donc
un exemple pour vous expliquer plus
clairement plus clairement ma solution
actuellement la chambre des communes du
canada il ya 3 138 députés
avec ma solution 169 des députés
seraient élus selon le mode
proportionnel
donc si on applique les résultats
d'élections fédérales de 2015
le parti libéral du canada obtenu 40 %
du vote populaire
il aurait obtenu 60,8 des 169 sièges
disponibles selon me de scrutin
proportionnel les avantages maintenant
ma solution a deux avantages majeurs le
50% du parlement il eu selon un mode de
scrutin uninominal à un tour accordent
de l'importance aux votes des régions et
l'autre 50% du parlement qui serait lui
ce long processus proportionnelle permet
un pâle une meilleure représentation
parlementaire des votes populaires mais
surtout changer notre mode de scrutin
peut changer la perception négative de
l'hygiène se fonde notre système
électoral et à une confiance
supplémentaire envers nos institutions
quand nous aurions le parlement plus
représentatif des intentions de vote des
électeurs
finalement le seul témoin de la
dégradation de l'environnement
d'inégalités l'évolution de la
technologie et autres tiens l'acteur
pour agir pour régler tous ces problèmes
le gouvernement
le changement passe par notre
gouvernement le parti au pouvoir peut
rédiger des projets de loi pour régler
et dîner les injustices si nous voulons
qu'une vision soit transmise à travers
vos projets de loi ou les sujets abordés
au parlement nous devons avoir le
parlement représentant l'opinion
publique
optant pour un mode de scrutin
proportionnel mixte compensatoire par
hasard dans la rédaction de mon texte ce
soir il m'a de montech c'est ma
présentation de ce soir la coalition
avenir québec rajouter à leur place on
leur intention de modifier de modifier
notre de ce critère pour qu'il devienne
mixte comme quoi consulter les jeunes ce
n'est pas une mauvaise idée
qu'en pensez vous
[Applaudissements]